Sharon Stone laughed in a reporter space
after being asked if she's experienced
sexual harassment you're laughing
[Music]
the actress sat down with CBS Sunday
morning over the weekend and laughed out
loud for a full 10 seconds
when asked if she ever experienced
inappropriate behavior during her time
in Hollywood this in a delicate way but
were you ever in a position like that
did you felt that you were uncomfortable
you're laughing but I don't know I don't
know if that's a nervous laugh or are
you kidding me of course I was laughs
after she pulled it together the
oscar-nominated actress got candid I've
been in this business for 40 years Lee
can you imagine the business I stepped
into 40 years ago well that's why I'm
looking like I look from nowhere
Pennsylvania I didn't come here with any
protection I've seen it all stone
attended the 2018 Golden Globes with her
son Rowan in tow and was one of many
celebs who wore black in support of The
Times up movement she says a change is
on the horizon we're starting to
acknowledge our own gifts as women and
not think that we have to behave as men
in order to be empowered or powerful or
valuable
[Music]
you